wow
you might think it's too early to talk
about holiday shopping before the leaves
even change but according to our
Bravo stage manager Giselle it's 82 days
she's a Cracker Jack on the floor but
this year is different because of high
inflation so take a look at this toys
cost nearly three percent more compared
to last year clothes are about five
percent more expensive don't like that
and household items are up more than 10
percent Nancy Chen is here today with
ways that you that can help you she says
Nancy good morning people want to be
helped let's hear Gail good morning to
you now on top of all that you just
mentioned the cost to send it is also
going up the U.S Postal Service
increased their shipping rates this past
weekend but just because everything
seems to be going up doesn't mean your
holiday spending has to
Halloween is still weeks away but some
people have already jump started the
gift giving season I'm just looking for
deals just because prices of things like
milk are going up have you started
holiday shopping yet no normally I would
start around November but this year has
to be different in a recent survey 38
percent of consumers say they're
starting holiday buying earlier than
usual and 58 say deals are more
important to them this year as Shoppers
look to take advantage of deeper savings
and spread out their spending to avoid
the inflation stained retail giants like
Amazon Walmart and Target are taking
note Amazon will hold a new Prime like
event starting October 11th boasting
holiday savings on thousands of Brands
Walmart says it'll be offering even more
deals this season and Target is holding
its annual deal days October 6 almost a
week earlier than last year retailers
are coming out of the gate as early as
possible because consumers may be
holding their money tight to the vest
Trey bodge is a smart shopping expert
the good thing about early shopping is
you're spreading your shopping out over
multiple pay periods if you have a job
right so it's a little bit less
impactful on your immediate budget but
says items like video game and console
bundles holiday gift sets and winter
apparel will be better priced later so
it's smarter to hold off how can
consumers feel confident that they are
getting the best deal if they're
starting so early retailers are offering
extended price protection and rest
assured that a lot of the retailers are
expanding their return windows for even
more savings try using browser
extensions that'll apply coupons at
checkout check your credit card's cash
back offers and make sure you do your
research and price compare is it kind of
weird to see people holiday shopping
when it's still the leaves are green and
people are wearing shorts
um no but it's weird to see them put up
the decoration
yeah
he is not wrong now even though we do
see these deals coming out earlier
consumer spending is expected to be down
this season still because of excess
inventory there are some unexpectedly
deep discounts right now on things like
casual clothing Furniture some
Electronics like TVs and classic toys
and games like Jenga and Battleship
speaking of toys since the hottest ones
can be hard to get shop early and check
back often for deals retailers have
already released their top toys lists
online with options to filter by Price
which is really helpful the Troy Insider
is just budgeting 15 more for toys this
year and check with local independent
stores because they have they could have
the toy you're looking for that might be
sold out at Big retailers I got a lot of
hate from people for talking about
holiday shopping already but it comes up
really nice it really does I'm thinking
looking at Trey Bosch number one love
her name love her look I thought she was
fantastic but there's always a hot toy
for Chris Christmas what is it this year
do you know yet I think this is
something a lot of people are you know I
think it depends on what age group
you're looking at so shop early I'm
saying Jenga and Battleship buy it once
buy it for life you can play with your
whole family
it's hard to beat
not for kids Tango the whole family
buying games that's not a new toy though
okay hard to beat Tony you're stuck in
the 80s now
proudly so and my family will be with me
yeah that's all you need